ya michel cymes enquête avec le
directeur de la revue positif
collaborateurs du masque et la plume
depuis 50 ans historien du cinéma vous
dites polanski est le plus grands
cinéastes vivants et j'accuse
et le meilleur film de l'année non j'ai
c'est un entretien mal transcrit par la
parisien je n'ai pas dit que polanski
était le plus grands cinéastes vivants
j'ai dit que c'est le plus grand
cinéaste français vivant d'accord quand
même plus limité quand même ce que je
veux dire
simplement c'est que dans toute cette
histoire ce qui me frappe c'est qu'on ne
parle pas et ça ne c'est pas du jeu du
pas du tout cela pour excuser polonsky
ce qu'est ce qu'il a fait dans les
années soixante dix est une chose et
physiquement extrêmement grave pour
laquelle personne ne peut lui donner un
assentiment cette évidence ce que je
veux dire c'est que la sphère gabriel
matzneff il ya quelques semaines a
ravivé toute cette époque
c'est une époque de licence sexuelle
inimaginable il imagine les plus grands
penseurs jean paul sartre
roland barthes michel foucault gilles
deleuze simone de beauvoir ont signé un
manifeste en défendant la pédophilie
était une activité pour eu tout à fait
légitime
bon aujourd'hui plus personne ne pense
l'aviation et et polonsky a baigné dans
ce climat
donc c'est pas du tout pour l'excuser
c'est pour dire qu'il faut
contextualiser dans lequel ça s'est
passé et deuxièmement ça s'est passé à
une époque où il n'y a pas eu tellement
de renous puisque après on lui a donné
la palme d'or à cannes
il a eu un oscar à hollywood j'étais au
festival de venise au mois de septembre
où il y avait trois mille journalistes
internationaux
c'était un enthousiasme unanime il n'y a
pas eu la moindre protestation ils
auraient pu avoir le lion d'or qui ne
lui a pas été accordée parce que il a
eut été en butte à l'hostilité de la
présidente du jury
lucrecia martel avait certainement
c'était le lion d'or qui lui était
donnée non il n'y a pas eu le moindre et
j'étais à berlin il ya une semaine
tous les journalistes péruvien italien
indien suédois à qui je disais que
polanski avait été sacrée plus grands
cinéastes français de l'année ils
étaient ravis d'accord donc c'est une
chasse à l'homme enfance qui est
organisée
c'est une chasse à l'homme où on ose
dire par exemple quand la la police on
voit des gaz lacrymogènes et servir à
gaz est plutôt polanski gaz est plutôt
polanski c'est quelqu'un qui nous dit
monsieur darroussin qui disait il ya
sept huit ans le film de ma vie c'est
est-ce bien sûr de ski prononcer le nom
et on sait que dans la tradition juive
enlevez le non à quelqu'un sait le faire
mourir et d'ailleurs les nazis le
faisait puisqu'il mettait des des
numéros sur la peau des captifs à
auschwitz pour leur enlever leur nom
donc ce qu'on veut ce qu'ils
disparaissent on veut qu'il reste
violence qui est qu'il n'y ait plus de
pôles ont simplement fait une victime
laissez-moi terminé je dis simplement
que sa consoeur à la cinémathèque finir
la cinémathèque française à montrer
l'ensemble de ses films 200 personnes
ont essayé de l'empêcher il ne fallait
pas montrer les anciens films de
polanski
le rêve c'est que polanski soit rayée de
l'histoire du cinéma
il ne le sera pas parce que toute son
oeuvre est un témoignage sur les
humilier et les offenser les sénateurs
benzema dames et toute son oeuvre est un
témoignage sur les humilier et les
offenses et sur le sort des femmes
tess rosemary's baby sur le sort des
juifs
le pianiste j'accuse sur le sort des
enfants
oliver twist le massacre d'un enfant ça
n'excuse rien lors des cinq sur neuf est
intègre et alors je vis que la roupie on
peut séparer l'homme de l'artiste mais
comme madame on peut vous répondre ou
pas du tout aller lorsque vous pensez
qu'il ya des gens aujourd'hui qui
regardent la télé des femmes qui ont
subi des violences et imaginer ce que
vous leur infliger comme souffrances par
vos propos vous facturer en ce qu'ils
lisent c'est une grande souffrance de
vous écouter leur coeur pour que
profiter
jeuland au jeu que l'on veut le rang
desquels propos je donnerai tout france
et des femmes je trouve que les femmes
qui ne voulaient poules d'ornement des
cieux je dis simplement libres il a fait
un nouveau contact
elle nous dit qu'il faut on peut pas
séparer l'homme de l'artiste et qu'elle
nous dit ensuite que son écrivain favori
c'est céline oui eh bien je me pose des
questions et la croisette par jamais la
vie de l'artiste
oui essayez de vous mettre à la place de
femmes qui ont souffert d' attaques qui
sont aujourd'hui reprochés à monsieur
polanski essayer d'avoir un peu de
pudeur de acte d'humanité dans vos
propos meurtre de ce cru c'est ce que
est ce que vous pensez y a pas
prescription peut pas dans la
destruction d'une femme qui a été violée
violente et donc essayer quand même au
moins de modérer votre propos pour
pensable notamment parce que pourquoi ce
jury est dérivée de la finir s'il vous
plaît mais ça ne vois pas pourquoi ce
prix est terrible ce prix les terribles
parce que si vous voulez c'est une
grande gifle à toutes les femmes qui ont
souffert et la grande hypocrisie
c'est de ne pas devoir bloquer les
chaudes au moment de la nomination parce
que derrière c'est un grand bal
d'hypocrites show où tout le monde a
tiré son épingle du jeu seul à finir et
je voudrais dire que 1 on aurait dû
bloquer ça parce qu on en connaissait
les conséquences
c'est dramatique ce que le message qui
est passé aux femmes qui souffrent et
plus vous derrière vous essayer de
défendre je vous l'enfoncer
parce que vous nous expliquer que je me
fais plus de peine pourrait y polanski
en ne citant pas que la souffrance de
toutes ces femmes dans ces postulats des
déplacés alors le jury un jury de venise
a fait affaire lui un jv good favoris
hollande ce qu'il ya eu ce flash n'est
de ce fait une gifle aux femmes tous les
jours
non là là vous êtes hors sujet bernard
laporte y est je pense pas mascarade
c'est une mascarade du début enfin bon
moi à commencer par adèle haenel
pourquoi il y va c'est très bien et tout
le monde sait que sur 12 possibilité
elle il va avoir un oscar
donc il va pas les armes dès le départ
tu dis que tu dis que j'ai des petits
films mais si oui si tout le monde tire
sur une piste était un particulier sans
surpasser d'accord dont maurice est une
mascarade depuis début 2010 était la
victime de ces fêtes mais lui aussi
courageux que ça lui ne prenait pas
est-ce qu'on peut s'épaissir arrive à se
reprocher c'est fini on regarde mais
pourquoi il n'aime pas le fait de pas
venir
il magnifie le doute existe levin et si
t'as rien à te reprocher il vient c'est
à dire et je suis désolé mais renonce
donc à koné et et la présentatrice et
qui s'en va je suis désolé 11h06
l'argent du beurre et la crémière
elle ne sait très bien aussi que sur 12
sur 12 aux possibilités va la voir et
donc j'attends cru et je fait le buzz et
je m'en vais à cinq minutes de la fin
pour moi c'est une mascarade du début
jusqu'à la fin et je trouve je trouve
comme le dit laurence que pour les
femmes qui ont eu terme qui ont subi
tout ça mais je me mets à la place à
leur place
c'est scandaleux c'est scandaleux s'ils
sont courageux mais c'est pour le ski
vous êtes très grand réalisateur
rapaille a levé ce qu un sportif c'est
un grand sportif il y avait ce que tu as
fait tu viens tu n'y as pas ton film on
le présente pas on pourrait s'arrêter
clair et courageux
dès le début